I think everybody's type 2012 was a
fluke like I got lucky or something I'm
the first black white whatever the first
woman to win Olympic gold medal in
boxing and I did it when I was 17 I
thought I would have endorsements and
sponsorships but you know that didn't
happen tonight I am the best in my box
on the work grew up in Flint Michigan
like you know when you talk you seem
like a bully or you seen pretty no how
do you want us to do your hair will do
your hair and I was I was home so I
can't express how great they want the
pretty girl back to everything I say
nothing's wrong with my personality
maybe this is the peak of my career
maybe 17 with it
maybe one Olympic gold medal and I start
having kids now
see the people in front are so used to
just somebody being successful and then
falling off Flint has limits nobody
wants to get in the sky and see what's
beyond a cloud type thing acting for
some people do they get stuck here and
they don't get out to be s because they
kind of get used to it and they see no
other way of life
he loved her line I cover mama can't of
the bargain with you I just went to the
school shopping and got two pair of
shoes but I can tell you go to school
play football you don't know [ __ ]
it's all happen to be here thank you
went to the cameras you can wait
September's no you must go tonight
my producer 27 bro I for not let you
decide your own life sacrifice your
education for her don't you think you
know everybody I think all the schools
dumping off you later bow because you
gonna make man I want to go you make me
mad
and what you gonna do about I know that
my family won't see me do well
but they don't know that some of the
things that they do can hurt me do you
know we always had a deal even when I
was younger
once you step into the gym or outside
problems stay out the gym you know like
I have everything to lose because I do
if I the longer I'm here the further I
drift away
you know drift back into being here I
really you know don't just want to walk
out on them but I've always kept my
career first before anything so that's
why I'm like the longer I stay the worse
it is for me
so it's time to go buddy let me get you
up though a lazy way
I have nothing but time to think nothing
but time to look out the window I wonder
about what I'm gonna do 15 20 years from
now I have to win to go back to the
Olympics you I don't win the Olympic
Trials
there is no Olympics there is no more
you was a boxing stipend we'll have to
move back to plan I do believe that when
another Olympic gold medal but just
because I believe it don't mean this
going to happen
good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the Olympic team trials for
women's boxing here Andrea
Memphis Tennessee
24 female boxers in the nation competing
for the chance to go to Rio de Janeiro
for the 2016 Olympic Games wins
middleweight winners bracket
Clarissa Shields in the red corner from
Flint Michigan against tika Hemingway in
the blue corner from Sylvania I can't
afford to have a bad fight we have a
close fight anymore they're gonna be a
lot harder on me now that I'm you know
top dog and he's either dominate or
don't she understands this time around
that it's much more than just about
winning gold that her image that her
personality play a much bigger role
people said that when you talk you seem
like a bully are you seeing pretty cocky
I don't have to change myself people to
accept me
I don't care one of my things
Wow
if you look at the web beautiful one-man
dictionary she had my face one day
it's half me in the back for two BOTS
the way that I do that's what I think is
really beautiful
and I know winner on the winners 165
I think everybody thinks that 2012 was a
fluke like I got lucky or something yeah
okay
they can't think that now